well it's still playing out and we
really don't know where it's going to go
this is one of the things that is very
uh disconcerting is not knowing where
things are going to go especially
in a country that has been ravaged by
warfare
for more than 40 years
uh hope we had all hoped at one time or
another
that peace will come to afghanistan
but unfortunately all that's been done
in the past 40 years
is merely a continuation of the
destruction and mayhem
that has afflicted afghanistan since the
soviet invasion in 1979.
so how do you think the withdrawal
should have been carried out should
president biden have delayed at the very
least or or renegotiated the president
trump deal
well it's not for me to tell him
surviving what he should have done
but he had enough time to set things in
motion in a much better way than they
happen in the end
when mr trump made the deal with the
taliban behind the back of the
government
it was inevitable that the government
would fall
its legitimacy was
was negated by that action
and mr biden accepted mr trump's deal
with the with the taliban but he had
any from the time that trump made the
deal until the withdrawal there was a
year or so
to set things in motion
to make it a better uh better
arrangement for for the troops
withdrawal and for the government
uh to uh to do what is necessary but
even the conditions of the withdrawal
were were you know
simply
haphazard and and unorganized
that was very unacceptable i think
and what is your assessment of the
modern day
taliban i mean you know them so
extensively particularly from
negotiating with them back in the 1990s
you'll have listened to all the
reassurances that they've been given to
the west particularly about uh the
rights of women education that they're a
very different taliban now
do you go along with that
we've had a very disappointing
experience with the taliban you
mentioned our negotiations with them in
the 1990s
to hand over aladdin from them to the
kingdom to face trial
for the crimes that he committed against
the kingdom in those days
in the beginning they agreed and then
they reneged
and subsequent to that
when mr karzai was president
he asked for saudi arabia to mediate
between the taliban and
and his government
the kingdom we received the delegation
from the taliban here and the kingdom
told them that
if they want to be serious about things
they must break their ties with al-qaeda
which they did not
so uh i don't know how much the world
can hold them to to their to their
statements uh if that is the background
that the kingdom has had with them
and what about in terms of recognizing
the taliban as the official government
of afghanistan we're in a bit of a kind
of limbo period at the moment where as
we're speaking we just hear that the
prime minister of the united kingdom
boris johnson has met with
representatives from the taliban we also
hear that the
the ambassador from afghanistan to the
united states from the the ghani
administration is still in place
should we recognize in the west the
taliban as the official government of
afghanistan
i don't think so i think they have to
show that they are serious about what
they said before
you give them
international recognition
it's not unusual for for countries not
to be recognized until
the
the world sees that they deserve that
that recognition and from their previous
conduct in the past i think they should
be held to account
uh and made sure that uh what they say
is is what they what they implement and
not simply uh vocal reassurances
so my view is that you should hold
recognition of the government but
i think the whole world should continue
to find ways to support the afghan
people
with
humanitarian aid
food aid
medicine etc etc and the united nations
organizations you know whether it is the
who or the world food program or such
humanitarian efforts should continue
uh to be the means to provide that aid
to the afghan people
it's fascinating what you say prince of
turkey about negotiating with the
taliban in the 1990s to hand over osama
bin laden if they had complied what a
different place the world would be right
now
that is a way of asking you do you think
the taliban could go that way and revert
and become a haven again for terrorists
like al qaeda islamic state perhaps
others
well al-qaeda is still in league with
them so um
they're not going to go other than to
keep them as allies
and uh we've seen how they've they've
displayed the al-qaeda as
a true friend over the years etc etc
but their areas with the so-called
islamic state and the recent explosion
in the mosque there was claimed by the
islamic state the explosion that took
place in the airport during the refugee
departures there was also claimed by the
islamic state
so it's not
a done deal for all
the terrorist groups that they will have
a haven there but definitely al qaeda
has a heaven there and any offshoots of
alpine
will equally have a haven there